empowering artists earlier in their
career before they've necessarily signed
a publishing deal or broken to be able
to create small form content on splice
hopefully like you said pay that
mortgage pay that rent with these little
snippets of sound and then when they go
in to get a deal they don't have to sign
like the first thing that comes over
them because they need you know like i
really want to smooth those power
dynamics out a bit and and i think
that's a long-term play for us is
continuing to you know we think about
two sides of the artist journey first we
think about making music and then how do
you make it in music because and that
gets at some point it transitions from
am i inspired to try to create can i
make something i like can i make
something others get feedback on it can
i make a dollar can i make a career can
i be a superstar we have to help people
along that curve once it gets to that
dollar or they're going to have to go
get a job so our goal is to raise that
curve make you a lifelong musician and
those power dynamics for those kinds of
session musicians that are incredibly
talented we think we can raise the curve
there for them by giving them in a way
it's what's happened with podcasting and
youtubers as well and so i had been
offered to be a cnbc contributor or
other networks as well and they wanted
to pay me et cetera other people wanted
me to do reality tv shows and i did
these negotiations and i was like
they're like yep for a network tv show i
was going to do with nbc that i did a
pilot for they were like 30 000 an
episode and i was like
my podcast makes 15 000 in episodes so
i'm gonna be on network tv and you're
going to be 30. the show's going to make
5 million an episode and cost 2 million
to produce and my podcast i make 30 000
a week on are you kidding me like this
doesn't make any sense and then you look
at the youtubers like they they get cast
in some tv show and they get offered
five thousand or ten thousand an episode
and they're like my youtube channel
makes a hundred thousand a month i'm
making a million dollars a year why
would i do that you can't get those
people and i think it's really
interesting you're talking about the
dynamic it does create that floor it
does create
that stability for them but i
interrupted you on the race to the
bottom you said you have a content team
that i think is i'm assuming
listening to that drummer from new
jersey who listens to liberty devito
copies it and then tries to draft off
his pack which we see in graphic design
and stock photography as well some great
photographer or some great designer
makes a beautiful logo and then all
these people steal it and adapt i'll
just say
charitably adapted but we all know
what's going on they're basically
mimicking it it's a charitable way of
saying it and stealing it would be the
uncharitable way of saying it
your group is looking for that right
yeah we're trying like i i wouldn't call
it like a full
i i think we do a really great job i
think people are proud of our library i
think we continue to get stricter and
stricter about it's like an app store
process in a will in a way like and it's
not perfect but it's we want things to
be we don't want people wasting their
time on splice like i really care that
every minute you're spending with us is
ex the fastest you can get to getting
that sound in your head or that creative
thought out into the world i want to
keep we say we're looking our the vision
statement for the company is a world of
more transcendent musical highs and
there's two sides of that there's the
fans getting the music that they're
deeply connected to so spiritually like
wow in their best moments and worst
moments but it's really on the creator
side about keeping them in their bliss
while they're creating and when you're
in your flow state flow state like when
you're in there it's the best feeling in
the world and technology and not not
having an idea for a sound and not being
able to get to it these things can break
you as music is complicated to be
perfectly honest it is a hard audio is a
way harder space than anyone realizes
and and so if we can keep them in their
bliss so that's the moment so i don't
want them wasting a single moment on a
bad sound or something
okay somebody's knocking my stuff off
what do you do you you're insinuated
like the app store has to deal with this
somebody makes angry birds somebody
makes like
pigs and it's like okay we get it you're
trying to steal the idea but yeah mark
pincus got in a lot of troubles with
zynga he was maybe like a mafia game or
some other tower defense game and
i came to his defense on this a little
bit which is like there are some genres
somebody makes right good fellows
somebody should still be able to make
scorsese should make good fellows after
the godfather and sopranos can come
after that
but
it is a real judgment call so you've had
to make these judgment calls how do you
make them i'm just yeah look i am
floored by our content there are humans
on this planet with ears that just blow
my mind like they can listen to any song
and be like i know where that came from
that came from that came from and what
we generally try to do is not shut the
artist down if something comes up and
just say hey we don't think this is
original enough can you do something
else and they're like cool i can do
something else so it's more of a
collaboration i would say of caring
about what's good for our users and what
we think we'll do better on the platform
by working with and we can't i don't we
don't do that with everyone but with the
especially our in-house stuff with a lot
of the higher profile artists work that
we do we really want to make it so that
they're showcasing their best talents
for our library how many in-house
artists you have just making samples
that would be like the equivalent of a
stock photography company and i think
some of them do this yeah hiring
photographers to work with them full
time giving them benefits which is crazy
in the photography industry doesn't
really exist anymore and then just
saying go take pictures of san francisco
we get requests for the golden gate
bridge all the time we need more golden
gate bridge so yeah you have a lot of
people doing that and at least 35 at
least 35 people making content and and
then more supporting the other content
creators so like really now where we get
to do some fun stuff and people's jobs
are like go capture the sounds of the
world like crazy like a subway train
yeah we have glaciers like the sounds of
what it's like walking a glacier and uh
and whale sounds and like things like
that and then also we're going into all
these different uh countries we went
over to senegal and did a whole set of
series of packs with local producers
there and we used the proceeds to build
a school like it's a real great way to
figure out how to bring the sounds of
the world to the world appropriately
yeah and leave the place better than we
found it by building a healthy
relationship around the world certainly
some of these musicians would say i
would think some high-end musicians
would say i don't want to give my music
away royalty-free established etc
how do you convince people who are on
the bubble of that like now if you're a
liberty devito you may be like yeah i
don't know i guess there's an argument
if you were high profile that this could
be even perceived as marketing it is
right and i'm taking a guess at that is
that true do people look at it and go
you know what i'm slash i want to be on
splice and i want to have a bunch of
slash sounds because it's marketing for
me if people put slash sounds in their
songs even if i don't get paid it builds
my profile exactly so i won't forget the
beginning of the journey when i would
show people the splice and they would be
like there's no way i'm giving you my
secret sauce this is how i make it but
then they would see the other artists on
the platform
and they would see oh wow i remember
when someone saw jess blaze was on the
platform and that was like oh
if he's on there maybe i should be on
there and it flipped from like people
holding back their secret sauce to that
to being a badge of honor to being on
the platform and too inspiring and you'd
be it'd be amazing because you could be
a leader of a genre and now all of a
sudden like your genre has blown up
because you've provided sounds to help
other people create it and i i think it
really that flip was really interesting
to watch which was that transition from
the no way am i giving my secret sauce
to that becoming part of the career
development process how much time and
money do you spend integrating a bunch
of different software products together
at your company let me guess way too
much time oh do is here to help odoo is
a suite of business apps that runs your
entire company on one platform they'll
streamline your workflow by bringing all
of that information together plus odoo's
integrations eliminate repetitive tasks
and data entry if you only need two or
three apps to optimize your workflow
that's all you pay for odoo won't stick
you with the bill for apps you don't use
odoo has an app for every business need
they offer 30 main apps that are updated
regularly and over 16 000 apps from
their active open source community you
can keep your books tight with their
financial software and their sales and
crm apps will help provide a clear and
organized view of your business so here
is your call to action your first app is
free forever and right now odoo is
offering a 1
000 credit on your first implementation
pack that's not a joke that's a thousand
dollars just go to odoo.com twist to
check it out that's odo.com
slash twist okay